okay so CNN which used to be the most
trusted name in news and now is just
something that's sort of between Fox
News and MSNBC I'm not really sure
anymore they have brought back crossfire
which is the worst of the partisan
access that we deal with endlessly in
this country you've got your two guys on
the left and your two guys on the right
and they give you talking points and
they yell at each other and they bring
on guessing you know what everyone's
thinking already and they stick the
party line okay that's fine but now it's
gotten even worse because Newt Gingrich
who's one of their hosts on the right
obviously he no longer has to disclose
when he's raising money for the very
people that he's interviewing so let's
first look at a statement by CNN's EVP
of standards and practices Rick Davis
this is their original statement before
the show launched if newt is helping fun
to candidate and that candidates on the
show or being discussed on the show of
course he'll disclose that disclosure is
important when it's relevant okay I
think we can all agree with that that
when the host of a show is raising money
for someone he's interviewing people
should know about that maybe a little
something on the bottom maybe a little
something to the camera but no they've
actually changed their policy over at
CNN and he no longer has to let's take a
look at the new policy we are clarifying
the policy and making a clear Newt
Gingrich is not in violation the policy
if a crossfire co-host has made a
financial contribution to a politician
who appears on the program or is the
focus of the program disclosure is not
required during the show since the
co-host political support is obvious by
his or her point of view expressed in
the program this is beyond beyond
bonkers ridiculous because he is the
host of a show and occasionally
Republicans don't always agree with
Republicans or Democrats don't always
agree with Democrats but they're
basically telling you this show is so
biased that we are just throwing all
journalistic practices out the window
are I know for a fact here at TYT we
would never do that jank would never let
me do it he would never do it himself
jr. I'll start with you on this one
because you are a toi tier isn't it's
exactly why we need independent news and
my news and everything and its basis as
basic as it is there's been times when
Jack was interviewing someone and he'd
say you know I'm gonna tell right now
I'm in favor of your candidacy I'm a
very campaign so let's put that on there
out in the first place and I'm sure you
didn't give me any money because we
don't have any money gift anything so
art or the raising of money the most
money raising thing we have our
fundraising we do is for Wolfpack which
has been repeated over and over again
the whole situation but so when it comes
to this is just protecting their we have
Newt Gingrich we can't lose his
perspective because that's awesome so we
have to keep his perspective on the show
so we want to change everything we do
because they feel they're being left
behind this all goes back to the to the
battle they need to get the ratings up
or to get ahead as we are talking about
before it's the reason why the discourse
in America is so low because all we can
think is team Democrat team Republican
and when you have a show that completely
exhibits it every day it's like a
basketball game every day between Timmy
team Democrat and Republican and
thinking well we have one of this one of
the superstars we have to keep him want
to change everything for that because if
we don't they feel they're gonna fall
apart so so is the problem here that
because because this is a daily show and
it's inside the beltway and one of the
hosts is a former presidential candidate
who's been around forever they'd have to
put that little disclosure of constantly
right wouldn't that disclosure if they
were really going to show you who he's
linked to and who they're all linked to
that disclosure would never go away I'll
be like pop-up video yeah right yeah
Justin to totally danger yourself that's
the thing with crossfire ah shishah oh
we be reminiscent tier everybody loves
papa be okay a crossfire is that you
know who gets hurt in crossfire it's
always the innocent stuck in between and
then there there are a lot of bravado a
lot of shouting to make it interesting
when there's no reason to shop for this
portion of the topic yeah just trying to
keep the old farts awake and they're
easy chairs wake up tops we're talking
about some hope why don't whatever yeah
all right and and it's become all
substance it's a substance list fluff
yeah it seems like barking for barking
sake yeah and though they'll cover a
topic they got that CNN standard well
that's all we can do right now
we'll have to leave it there the wolf
blitzer bail out right yeah and and when
you just look at their sponsors and you
just see who runs the whole operation
how how could they yeah so who they
possibly not be abridged at this point
yeah so whose fault is this though is it
is it this television networks is this
CNN's fault because they're really
backtracking on pretty basic
journalistic standards that you have
it's really low fruit or is this really
the fault of the the political machine
because everybody is connected or is it
a combo or is it or I missing something
altogether I want to put all of it on
CNN because I mean your edges of the
practices you had your out your
guidelines to what you'd normally follow
and I mean Lisa put out they don't know
how hard you had to scour to get this
information about the change political
got it yeah it wasn't that hard so they
put an object and basically thinking
well we've run the gambit of all of our
BS we throw at American so if we change
our policies and say we're not going to
keep telling you how we're breaking your
rules that we set up in the first place
they're gonna forget about me because
they really don't care because all they
care about is seeing more people yell at
each other the only we need that rather
than real practices yeah so then is the
other problem here that these guys
they're all friends to you know what I
mean it's not just about money but
everyone you see on CNN constantly
they're playing golf together they're
doing the White House correspondent they
all want to be invited to the same
parties and go to the same dinners and
they put a puppet show on for the kids
yeah pretending they're on opposite
sides basically you know yeah you know
as it that way the camera so close to
all their heads in cross it actually
looks like puppets it's just two
floating heads with that black
background it's a team america yeah the
picture in my head of like well now I'm
dating myself when I caught I still
called the WWF I still oh yeah right so
what would when you know when when the
bad guy comes out in interviews with
Gene Oakland yeah and he goes I'm gonna
kick your ass just once I get out there
and then you know off-screen they're the
best of friends there's been guys that
said the bad guys are wrestling are the
nicest guys and a lot of times the good
guys are wrestling or actually [ __ ]
in real life all right and really
the bad guys are the nicest ones you
meet in person so they're out there to
do things for the cat you know there's a
show they can do it and disclosed well
you know Triple H actually doesn't
dislike the rock actually these wet
dinner last night they're just along
great make it look they can take apart
my belief system yes and on that I'll
date myself and let you all know that I
learned my entire political philosophy
from Jake the snake Roberts hey guys the
Reuben report is brought to you by
Cooper calm they've got 75 percent off
dog and cat choose toys accessories home
goods and more use code RR for twenty
percent off your next purchase the link
is right down there